otra Victoria para el gobierno de Manuel
macron los diputados afines al
mandatario lograron despojar de sentido
el proyecto de ley que busca derogar la
reforma de pensiones aprobada a la
fuerza por el gobierno de Elizabeth
bonda sin embargo sus promotores no se
dan por vencidos luego de abandonar la
sala de forma intempestiva e intentar
obstaculizar el debate sugirieron que
introducirán una enmienda al proyecto de
ley con el mismo objetivo derogar la
reforma de pensiones sería esa la única
forma y la primera vez en que la
asamblea en pleno podría votar
específicamente la edad de jubilación de
los franceses y también el último
recurso antes de que la reforma entre en
vigor en septiembre de este año problema
la presidenta de la cámara baja podría
desestimar la iniciativa basada
nuevamente en otro acapite de la Carta
Magna francesa relacionado con las
finanzas del Estado otra vez el gobierno
y sus legisladores en tela de juicio por
lo que la oposición cataloga como otro
atropello legal pero legítimo a la
voluntad popular para la primera
ministra sin embargo toda esta maniobra
es una venta de ilusión una estrategia
demagógica de la oposición que le viene
como anillo al dedo a pocos días de la
décimo cuarta jornada Nacional de
protestas contra la reforma de pensiones
prevista para el próximo martes